hey folks home ribera here bringing you
the live coverage of e3 2014 games wats
coverage continues I am with jiron
roading yes community manager here at
the sony booth what's up drone very good
very good so you guys are showing off
some Killzone shadow fall intercept
online co-op play what's what's going on
with that yeah well it's it's you have
like a team of four players use you're a
talented squad alpha so what you're
trying to do is that you have like three
different points where you want to want
to have some intelligence so you want to
capture that from the hell them from the
hell gasps people and point the goal is
to do it as quick as possible so you're
racking up points so you need to have
all three of those intercept points you
need to need to have them in your
position to gather points every action
you do in the game so you kill somebody
use your abilities you get points as
well well let's take a look at some
gameplay right here go ahead and call
push in so where are we right now what
map are we on let me see this is let me
check oh this is the this is the market
this is the market now okay so we have
let me see what we always playing we got
one medic on here we got assault on here
and a marksman and there's also a text
dish that the tactician is playing on
the other screen and tactician has the
ability G placed hurts the nematic as
you can see here he has ability to heal
people or to revive people he's like a
little zone that posted oz is healing
abilities and then he can also drop to
supply boxes he's not really a guy that
should be on the forefront of the field
because he's moral support is a
supportive role um if you look at the
other squeeze I am assault for instance
he has the ability to captured the
points much quicker than the other one
so gave if the helghast have captured a
point he can capture the point really
quickly and then he has like the speed
dash ability as well and he can these
are all three of these guys playing on
the same team right now or they're all
playing on scenting so let's talk about
the amount of multiplayers that you can
you can have
map is it like 12 v 12 or I did this is
this is purely co-op so what you do
really clock it really caught up there's
like any kills and reveals to have them
looks player and it's 24 players max but
this is purely covino serving off
intercept is pure co-op for people
against AI so everybody has a specific
role in this in this dispersion and then
where does this fit into the general
kills known universe where does this
plotline lie well the plot line is that
they have to maintain those points
because they want to intercept
intelligence from the hell gasps that's
the whole this whole deal and the
quicker they do it the quicker they de
risa to score limit so the score limit
now sundays on 1500 points cuz they
reach it in time they they jump on the
leaderboard so they'll get more points
and the quicker you do it the better it
is for a free faction and let's talk
just just tack you guys are running
1080p 60 frames i see uh yeah what's
beautiful man yeah yeah it says one of
our oldest that's just the thing you
know with the game is out calzone is out
we have like the whole engine is
optimized so we could build from that
and that's that's a that's a really good
benefit of the operator 7 this one cool
so uh let's talk about where you guys
are at in terms of release are you guys
pretty close to letting this thing fly
or what yeah yeah it's going to be
released of 24th i think that 24th of
june yeah so right around the corner
that's right on the corner it's it's
free for season pass holders and it's
going to be there's also going to be
standalone version so this this version
window least on the 24th is for people
they have the game and they're going to
be standalone version in august so you
don't have to have the game to enjoy
intercept all right great drone thank
you so much for joining us real quick
and uh again let's just remind the folks
at home name the game and release date
yeah Killzone intercepts going to fall
on twenty-fourth of June alright cool
thanks for joining us gamespot's
coverage of e3 2014 continues we'll
throw it back to the stage right now
you